er ist der mann
er ist der mann der regierung der im
feuer steht bundesgesundheitsministerin
sparen gerade eben ist er hier vor dem
axel springer haus angekommen
seit wochen muss sich sparen gegen die
kritik verteidigen das zu wenig
impfstoff bestellt wurde zu langsam die
impf wird und zu zögerlich verhandelt
wurde
ich will von ihm jetzt wissen was hat er
falsch gemacht und vor allem wie kann es
jetzt schneller gehen und was kommt
wirklich beim impfstoff gipfel morgen
raus das den verzweifelten menschen
hilft und das möchten wir besprechen mit
jan sparen da jetzt schon im studio
sitzt entspannt duckt sich nicht weg er
stellt sich den fragen von bild vielen
dank dafür ersparen und schönen guten
abend wurden haben wir uns ersparen wir
wollen anfangen mit einem fall in
leverkusen in einem seniorenheim der uns
schockiert hat ein neues corona drama
wieder in einem altenheim bild am
sonntag berichtet heute über die
schockierende geschichte des awo
pflegeheimes leverkusen rheindorf hier
wütet seit ende dezember bereits das
corona virus und zwar die besonders
ansteckende briten mutation 32 bewohner
sind derzeit infiziert auch 25
mitarbeiter die traurigste zahl aber 15
heimbewohner sind in diesem monat mit
corona gestorben
auch sie johanna bratke hier ein foto
von august 2017 als die politik in
bratislava
der damalige spd-kanzlerkandidat schulz
und gesundheitsexperte lauterbach
jetzt ist johanna bratke tod und das
trotz impfung am 30 dezember gab es hier
im awo-heim die ersten
auch für johanna brand gesetzt aber der
volle impfschutz der setzt erst wochen
danach ein für sie kam die impfung
offenbar zu spät
herr spahn was sagen sie angehörigen die
jetzt sagen würde deutschland schneller
impfen dann könnte meine mutter meine
großmutter noch leben das schmerzt mich
jeder ausbruch in einem pflegeheim jeder
todesfall jeder schwere verlauf schmerzt
und ganz besonders in den
pflegeeinrichtungen wenn das virus
einmal den weg hinein gefunden hat dann
schlägt es brutal zu bei dem besonders
verwundbaren und deswegen kann ich da
nur eben sagen 'das dass ich das leid
das da entsteht sehr und auch mit kreide
wie jeder der ein herz hat
aber was ist mit der schuldfrage die ich
gestellt habe wenn jetzt angehörige
sagten herr bundesgesundheitsministerin
sparen wenn sie schneller impfstoff
besorgt hätten dann könnte meine mutter
konnte meine großmutter noch leben
trifft sie das die schuld ist erst mal
beim virus ich meine wir haben einen
virus das neu auf die welt gekommen ist
eine jahrhundert pandemie mit der wir
gerade umgehen müssen und das tragische
leben vor allem wenn das virus sich in
eine pflegeeinrichtung hinein wo ja auch
abstand schwer es so viele menschen auch
mit demenziellen erkrankungen sind wo ja
viele auch im früher gesagt haben die
totale isolation dieses phasenweise
gegeben hat die hat auch viel einsamkeit
und leid verursacht haben sie empfunden
als gefängnis ohne gitter so ist das ja
von einigen beschrieben worden
und das eben mit der balance die wir
jetzt versuchen und wo auch die
pflegeeinrichtungen jeden tag darum
ringen besuch oder überhaupt kontakt zur
außenwelt möglich zu machen und
gleichzeitig infektionsrisiken zu
reduzieren dass in dieser balance leider
immer wieder auch dieses virus in die
einrichtung sie sprechen jetzt ganz
bewusst auf man nicht über den impfstoff
und das virus hat ja nicht zu spät
impfstoff bestellt sondern sie zuerst
einmal ist das virus für leid und tod
verantwortlich und für schwere
krankheitsverläufe und es ist ja
begonnen worden
zu impfen wir hatten eine zulassung am
27.12 am 23 12 07 20 12 begonnen zu
impfen in deutschland seitdem wird
geimpft warum sich foto kunz mineralien
schon
sehr wichtig für uns einmal dass wir
einsehen die herausforderung hier in
dieser pandemie das ist das virus und
wir müssen vermeiden dass das virus sich
ausbreiten und verbreitet das virus an
sich ist ja tot das kann sich alleine
nicht bewegen das bewegt sich durch uns
auch in eine pflegeeinrichtung aber wäre
es nicht an der zeit wenn sie jetzt den
fall in leverkusen sehen den angehörigen
nicht nur das beileid auszusprechen
sondern sich auch zu entschuldigen dass
deutschland so viel langsamer als
großbritannien usa israel und andere ist
wir haben uns ja bewusst entschieden für
eine ordentliche zulassung der
tatsächlich drei vier wochen länger
gedauert als eine note zulassung ich bin
dabei sehr sicher dass wir das was wir
auch an zusätzlichem vertrauen durch das
zulassungsverfahren erhalten und
erhalten werden auf der strecke auch
auszahlt moment reden wir sehr viel über
knappheit und da verstehe ich auch die
ungeduld vor allem auch angesichts solch
tragischer beispiele wie sie gerade aus
leverkusen gebracht haben natürlich
gleichzeitig werden wir eben auch in
eine situation kommen wo es um
impfbereitschaft geht weil um diese
pandemie unter kontrolle zu bekommen um
ausbrüche in pflegeeinrichtungen ganz
vermeiden zu können brauchen wir einen
sehr hohen anteil der bevölkerung der
sich impfen lässt und dafür ist
vertrauen wichtig und für vertrauen ist
eine freundliche zulassung wichtig davon
bleibe ich weiter überzeugt ein kollege
von mir hat mit den angehörigen
telefoniert da in leverkusen die sind
schwer betroffen
und sie sind sauer auf die
bundesregierung auf die kanzlerin auf
sie auch ursula von der leyen deswegen
noch mal die frage haben sie sich
persönlich nichts vorzuwerfen
zuerst einmal jemand der ein todesfall
zu beklagen hat ein trauerfall in der
familie hat jedes recht sauer zu sein
das verstehe ich auch gut die frage ist
ja was wann also habe ich wider besseren
wissens etwas nicht entschieden oder
entschieden ein wir alle entscheidenden
phasen von unsicherheit in einer
jahrhundert situation in einer pandemie
jeden tag auf jeder ebene und müssen
neben dann immer wieder auch mit neuen
erkenntnissen natürlich entscheidungen
anpassen das ist seit beginn dieser
pandemie so das ist auch im moment so
sie haben in dieser gesamten pandemie so
viel über verzeihen gesprochen immer
wieder wir werden uns noch verzeihen
müssen warum sagen sie in so einer
situation jetzt ja das ist scheiße
gelaufen das hätte besser laufen können
wir haben fehler gemacht
die frage ist ja mal was hätte jetzt in
dieser konkreten situation
bezogen auf den fall in leverkusen diese
gerade geschildert haben denn anderswo
laufen können jetzt kann man immer dass
ich meine das impfen ist ja begonnen
worden offensichtlich aber es dauert
seine zeit bis die wirkung des impfens
eintritt und wir haben überhaupt zwölf
monate nach beginn dieser pandemie drei
impfstoffe verfügbar das hätte vor drei
monaten niemand erwartet dass überhaupt
jetzt schon ein aber da ist ja der
erfolg der pharmaindustrie und nicht der
bundesregierung hat dazu sage ich gleich
noch was das hat schon durchaus einen
gemeinsamen anteil
und gleichzeitig haben wir immer gesagt
zu beginn jetzt kann das impfen wenn
dann nur eben individuell individual
schutz bieten also dann wenn beide
impfungen erfolgt sind und die volle
wirksamkeit da ist aber wie er insgesamt
als gesellschaft wir müssen weiterhin
die schutzmaßnahmen aufrecht erhalten
also geraten nicht nur in
pflegeeinrichtungen aber auch geht es um
hygiene konzepte geht es um die test
konzepte geht es um abstand und masken
tragen all das werden wir auch wenn das
impfen begonnen ist weiterhin haben
müssen übrigens weil sie gerade israel
erwähnt haben und das vereinigte
königreich ja dort ist prozentual schon
mehr geimpft worden aber auch dort ist
reiner sinnvoll lockdown ist dass wir es
eben nicht unter kontrolle auch dort
heißt es weiterhin in jeder lebenslage
bestmöglich aufeinander aufbauen ich
möchte ihnen einmal zeigen was der
alterspräsident des bundestages hermann
otto solms gesagt hat zu der frage wie
schnell geimpft wird in deutschland er
hat gesagt ist sterben laufen leute die
hätten geschützt werden können das ist
eine kern verantwortung der
bundesregierung und dabei hat sie
versagt es hätten das jetzt sicher ein
bis zwei millionen deutsche geimpft
werden können und weiter sie können sich
ausrechnen wie viele davon aufgrund der
nachlässigkeit der bundesregierung
mittlerweile gestorben sind hat er otto
solms auch keine ahnung ich kenne und
schätze jansons sehr gut aber an dieser
stelle bleibe ich dabei für tod und leid
ist das virus verantwortlich und wir
müssen ist diesem virus und dafür
ergreifen wir die maßnahmen seit zwölf
monaten so schwer wie es eben geht
machen sich zu verbreiten krankheit zu
bringen leid zu bringen und wir müssen
jeden tag die richtige balance finden
jeder einzelne von uns und wir als
gesellschaft zwischen dem was so viel
normalität wie möglich ist und
gleichzeitig ebenso viel vermeiden von
infektion und leid wie es ihm aber
machen sie es da nicht ein bisschen
einfach wenn sie sagen tod und leid
bringt das virus wenn wir wie gesagt auf
die anderen länder schauen die das eben
besser organisiert haben und es gibt ja
einen kausalen zusammenhang zwischen
einer schnelleren bestellung und leid
minderung und einer langsameren
bestellung und methoden also ich sage
zuerst einmal nochmal israel zum
beispiel ist immer noch im fond lockt
aber das ändert ja nichts also über 30
prozent schon geimpft sind
darf ich kurz zwei sätze israelis sind
ein volk da und weiterhin weil es sehr
hohe infektionszahlen hat und weiterhin
sehr viele schwere verläufe und wir
können ja gerne kurz mal beispielhaft
schauen das vereinigte königreich hat
sich zur not zulassung entschieden und
hat die zweitimpfung länger verschoben
also dient das intervall länger
auseinandergezogen als empfohlen ist um
mehr menschen erst zu impfen
wir haben uns sehr bewusst entgegen
dagegen entschieden weil insbesondere
pflegebedürftige den vollen schutz erst
haben nach der zweiten impfung wir
machen die zweitimpfung im vorgesehenen
rahmen und ich halte diese entscheidung
auch für richtig zweitens muss man auch
die absoluten zahlen sich anschauen
israel hat neun millionen einwohner
ich weiß gar nicht genau 34 millionen
dosen bis jetzt verläuft diese
größenordnung an dosen haben wir auch
wir haben aber 80 millionen einwohner
israel hat zehn prozent der bevölkerung
älter als 60 als 65 in deutschland sind
über 20 prozent älter als 65
also natürlich ist der ältere
bevölkerungsanteil bei einer
gesellschaft die jünger ist früher
geimpft als bei einer gesellschaft bei
der im der anteil so viel größer ist wie
hier bei uns in deutschland und deswegen
verstehe ich den vergleich gut und es
ist beeindruckend was israel auch
hinbekommen hat und hinbekommt jeden tag
aber gleichzeitig sind doch ganz
unterschiedliche verhältnisse schon bei
der größe des landes
sie sprechen die krisenmanager an
in den verschiedenen ländern johnson
donald trump benjamin netanjahu die
haben es besser geschafft und wenn über
krisen management in deutschland
sprechen dann ziehen viele einen
vergleich zu dem was in hamburg passiert
ist 1962 zehntausende menschen haben
sich auf hausdächern oder bäumen vor den
wassermassen in sicherheit gebracht und
der damalige hamburger innensenator
helmut schmidt zögerte
bitte persönlich mehrere militärische
oberbefehlshaber aus ganz europa schickt
hubschrauber sturm boote und pioniere
nach hamburg stunden später treffen die
helfer ein später räumt der senator ein
dass er sich damals mit dem einsatz des
militärs im inland bewusst über
grundgesetz und hamburgische verfassung
hinweggesetzt hat für ihn zählte es ging
um viele viele menschenleben und jede
minute zählt ersparen warum haben wir
keinen helmut schmidt warum agieren sie
und die verteidigungsministerin nicht
wie helmut schmidt 1962 und was würde
denn daraus folgend aus ihrer sicht aus
meiner sicht würde daraus folgen das
schon längst viel mehr soldaten vor
altenheim stehen dass dort getestet wird
und dass dadurch möglicherweise so ein
fall wie in leverkusen hätte verhindert
werden können
also zuerst einmal ich schon wert darauf
dass wir gesetze und das grundgesetz
einhalten und nicht auch nicht in einer
krise den rechtsstaat und die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung und in frage
stellen das ist mir schon ein sehr sehr
wichtiger grundsatz in jeder pandemie in
jeder krise in jeder notlage
zum zweiten sind ja hat helmut schmidt
falsch gehandelt damals sind ja sie
haben jetzt gefragt was übertragbar ist
und was nicht und das ist übrigens was
anderes ob sie eine sturmflut haben die
schlimm genug ist aber doch zeitlich
begrenzt und natürlich sehr akut auch
erst mal eine reaktion braucht oder wir
jetzt seit zwölf monaten in einer
pandemie sind zum zweiten sind ja
soldatinnen und soldaten in den
gesundheitsämtern schon seit langem noch
viel zu wenig weiß ich dass das ist
jetzt ihre bewertung viele tausende
soldaten schon seit langen in den
gesundheitsämtern im einsatz
sie können aber immer nur im einsatz
sein wenn tatsächlich die jeweilige
zuständige behörde das rathaus das
kreishaus eben auch um diese
unterstützung bitte aber das versteht
doch kein mensch mehr sparen das ist das
klingt nach bürokratie in deutschland
und das kostet menschenleben die
kanzlerin hat gesagt das ist eine
naturkatastrophe sie haben sagt gesagt
die sturmflut ist was anderes aber wenn
die kanzlerin sagt es ist eine
naturkatastrophe und jeder tag zählt da
müssen sie doch entschlossene handeln
wir haben ja bei den pflegeeinrichtungen
zum beispiel als die tests zur verfügung
stand in ausreichender zahl ab
november in etwa die kosten übernommen
was sie müssen nicht nur ausreichen
sondern die qualität muss auch stimmen
welche das übrigens mal sagen darf auch
für debatten dieser tage es geht nicht
nur darum irgendwie zu testen das
testergebnis sollte auch ziemlich
korrekt seien zu viele falsch negative
tests dann haben zu viele den eindruck
sie hätten es nicht obwohl sie es haben
deswegen ausreichend gute und qualitativ
gute tests gab es ab november ab dann
übernimmt der bund auch die kosten
übrigens nicht nur die kosten für den
test sondern auch fürs personal und
viele einrichtungen haben damit auch
sich zusätzliches personal organisiert
das sind zum teil 10 15.000 euro im
monat
die daneben zusätzlich für personal
übernommen werden und davon kann man ja
schon auch zwei drei leute beschäftigen
die regelmäßig die tests machen
und ja objektiv klappt das in einigen
einrichtungen oder in vielen
einrichtungen auch deutlich besser als
in anderen das gilt auch für jene
konzepte und schutzkonzepte und deswegen
ist es natürlich richtig da wo es nicht
gelingt aus eigener kraft auch
unterstützung zu geben das haben wir
schon vor dem einsatz der soldatinnen
und soldaten auch die
wohlfahrtsorganisation das rote kreuz
viele haben immer wieder aufs neue
bereits unterstützt und auch
unterstützung angeboten aber eines
bleibt soldatinnen und soldaten im
inland können nur zum einsatz kommen
wenn sie auch angefordert werden
angeboten seitens des bundes werden sie
seit monaten
also war das falsch wie helmut schmidt
damals agiert hat der hat ja gesagt er
hat sich über das grundgesetz
hinwegsetzen ich ganz sicher herunter
obwohl es jetzt die debatte rund um
helmut schmidt im jahr 2009 aber die
debatte ist wichtig warum nicht längst
viel mehr bundeswehrsoldaten vor den
altenheim stehen und diese schützen das
ist eine entscheidende debatte momentan
sie nicht ich sage noch einmal wenn im
inland in friedenszeiten können
soldatinnen und soldaten nur dann zum
einsatz kommen wenn sie tatsächlich auch
angefordert werden
sie sind im angebot so zusagen für die
pflegeeinrichtungen für die kommunen vor
ort sie sind geschult
sie können das machen es läuft ja auch
an vielen stellen an
und das ist eine zusätzliche
unterstützung die frage ob in
pflegeeinrichtungen getestet werden kann
oder nicht hängt ja nicht ausschließlich
davon ab ob soldatinnen und soldaten es
tun weil ich sage noch einmal seit dem
herbst werden die kosten für die tests
wie auch für die personalkosten
übernommen und in vielen
pflegeeinrichtungen gelingt es seitdem
auch gut aber eben nicht ausreichend in
allen pflegeeinrichtungen altenheime ein
stichwort sie haben dazu anfang januar
ein interview gegeben bei rtl im tv zu
dem thema wie schnell dort geimpft
werden kann wenn wir schaffen im laufe
des januars und das können wir schaffen
wenn wir schaffen im laufe des januars
alle bewohnerinnen und bewohner von
pflegeheimen zu impfen
dort wo das virus besonders brutal
zuschlägt wo es sehr viele todesfälle
sehr viele schwere verläufe gibt dann
macht das schon einen entscheidenden
unterschied im pandemie verlauf und
dieses ziel wie gesagt können wir im
januar erreichen und das wollen und
werden wir auch mit den ländern
erreichen
das wollen und werden wir auch erfahren
wie viel prozent wie viele menschen sind
jetzt in altenheimen fehlheim gibt stand
heute sind etwa 70 prozent werden wir
davon ausgehen dass etwa das ist so eine
unterschiedliche rückmeldung das ist
noch die statistisch erhoben 80 90
prozent der pflegeheimbewohner sich
impfen lassen wollen
das nehmen wir nicht 100 prozent das
angebot an sind wir also schon ja noch
nicht ganz da aber ende januar da schon
sehr weit vorangekommen ist gab ja seit
dem interview dass sie gerade gezeigt
haben und heute zum beispiel
verschiedene lieferung etwa von beyond
ich was natürlich auch diese
impfkampagne dort zeitlich etwas
verzögert und deswegen übrigens den teil
sollten sie dann dazu berichten haben
bund und länder mittlerweile auch
beschlossen eben dass spätestens bis
mitte februar alle pflegeeinrichtungen
geimpft werden sondern ein angebot
erhalten haben und stand heute können
die länder das jedenfalls schaffen was
die liefermengen angeht was die dosen
zahlen geht was die strategie angeht und
eine abfrage bei den ländern wie weit
sie dabei sind die läuft auch gerade man
hat dennoch das gefühl sie versprechen
immer wieder was neues und sie müssen
das dann immer wieder kassieren baum
machen sie so viele konkrete versprechen
bis ende januar das können sie jetzt
nicht halten das war tatsächlich immer
wieder mit dem hinweis versehen das
dafür natürlich die erwarteten
lieferungen erfolgen müssen
das gilt für jede aussage die ich mache
aber ich merke ja
ich muss das komma hinter jedem satz den
ich mache immer noch dazu sagen unter
der voraussetzung dass die annahme stand
heute wie sie sind und das was wir
erwarten dürfen sich auch so erfüllt das
ist in dieser ausnahmesituation so dass
nicht alles dann sich so ergibt wie es
geplant war dass dinge sich verändern
das war weil das produktions kapazitäten
heruntergefahren werden vorübergehend um
sie dauerhaft zu erhöhen das ist ja das
was wir gerade in belgien im kreis
bamberg von pfizer sehen es wird jetzt
für zwei wochen weniger geliefert damit
anschließend mehr geliefert werden kann
das war eben nicht absehbar also sind
immer die anderen schuld und deswegen
ich habe doch gerade gesagt herr uns
haben wollte deswegen ist wichtig immer
dazu zu sagen stand heute mit dem wissen
von heute mit dem was wir heute erwarten
dürfen lassen sich die ziele erreichen
wenn sich in den bedingungen was
verändert verändert sich natürlich auch
bei der möglichkeit das ziel zu
erreichen etwas viel fürsorge haben sie
dass das sommer versprechen sie können
zimmer umdrehen weil ich ich nehme wahr
dass ihre wahrnehmung und auch die
wahrnehmung der überschriften der
letzten wochen immer ein und auch die
wahrnehmung der menschen darf ich kurz
von debakel und desaster die rede ist
man kann es auch andersrum sagen dass
wir ein jahr nach beginn der pandemie 70
prozent der bewohnerinnen und bewohner
von pflegeeinrichtungen geimpft haben
halte ich weiterhin für ein großes glück
dass wir drei impfstoffe zur verfügung
haben halte ich weiterhin für ein großes
glück dass wir am wochenende den ländern
mitteilen konnten mit dem stand den die
hersteller uns gegeben haben dass wir
1,7 millionen dosen mehr ist 22 februar
erwarten dürfen als geplant halte ich
für ein großes glück ein hersteller
liefert 40.000 weniger
daraus entsteht dann die überschrift
nächste panne nächstes desaster
natürlich auch sagen können obwohl ein
hersteller 40.000 weniger liefert werden
insgesamt 1,7 millionen dosen mehr
geliefert
also ist man manchmal auch eine frage
natürlich wie man es wahrnehmen will
also jetzt wirklich schultern einem
freien land ist es doch völlig absurd
wenn sie es anders wahrnehmen als ich
aber wenn sie mich schon einladen darf
ich ja vielleicht auch meine wahrnehmung
der dinge darstellen
wir möchten darüber sprechen mit
jemandem der es wissen muss
landrat in heinsberg uns jetzt
zugeschaltet
herr pusch sie haben mitbekommen was
ansparen die parteikollege im übrigen
zur situation zur impfung situation
gesagt hat erklären sie uns mal wie
läuft das momentan vor ort was ist mit
der organisation und wie dramatisch ist
es mit den impftermin also wir haben
tatsächlich eins kann ich bestätigen
etwa bis mitte nächsten monats gehen
davon aus dass die pflegeheime
tatsächlich dann auch durch geimpft sind
wie man so schön sagt
das ist natürlich hängt das sind dass
hinter dem zeitplan her den man
ursprünglich mal hatte das haben in den
nächsten wochen ja in vielen bereichen
erlebt was in den letzten tagen hier und
das ist habe ich auch laut gegeben habe
für unmut gesorgt hat war weniger das
man jetzt sagt da hat sich etwas
verzögert oder ist irgendwas nicht so
aufgetreten sondern eigentlich dass der
eindruck entstand bei den bürgern hier
vor ort insbesondere bürgertelefon das
was oben erzählt wird was als
erfolgsmeldung verkauft wird das hat mit
der eigenen lebenswirklichkeit und so
wie man dann die impf terminvergabe
beispielsweise erlebt oder wie man das
was in den nächsten wochen monaten zu
erwarten ist an impfungen sowie auch die
erwartungshaltung entstanden ist muss
man dazu sagen nicht so ganz
übereinstimmt und das mal vorsichtig
auszudrücken
also ich glaube die menschen können eine
ganze menge auch an erklärungen
verstehen ich habe der spanier glaube
ich auch einiges gerade ganz gut erklärt
aber sie können nicht verstehen warum
man beispielsweise einige einigen
herstellern hinterherläuft die einem
quasi jetzt irgendwo sagen naja ich
schulde euch gar nicht so viel dosen ihr
habt mir vor ich habe euch nur
versprochen ich bemühe mich möglichst
viel boden zu verschaffen
und da muss ich natürlich auch sagen da
liegt natürlich auch eine ganze menge
verantwortung aus meiner sicht bei der
beschaffungspolitik der eu
denn wir hätten mehr impfdosen von allen
drei haben können wenn man im sommer mit
mehr risiko daran gegangen wäre das ist
glaube ich etwas was wir glaube ich
nicht mehr so hier so ausdiskutieren
müssen im detail
natürlich kann man sich als
bundesregierung als er das
gesundheitsminister nicht komplett ex
kopieren indem man sagt das haben wir
jetzt der eu überlassen ich verstehe
dass man das der überlassen hat weil man
keine deutschen alleingänge machen
wollte wenn man noch irgendwo
solidarität pflegen will aber natürlich
wir müssen und das war mein anliegen
eigentlich wir müssen das vertrauen der
bürger wieder gewinnen wir müssen den
signalisieren leute ganz offen wir
machen manöverkritik das sind einige
sachen suboptimal gelaufen uns mal vor
sich auszudrücken
wir haben daraus gelernt und wir gucken
jetzt aber trotzdem nach vorne auf dem
impfgipfel müssen wir uns alle mal in
die augen gucken da gibt sich darum der
eine dem anderen sagt was er alles
falsch gemacht hat sondern die
gretchenfrage ist schaffen muss in den
nächsten monaten mehr impfstoff zu
organisieren damit war der pandemie
wirklich den stachel ziehen können denn
ich glaube dass unser aller leben sich
in dem moment sehr stark normalisieren
wird wenn wir die alten die kranken die
schwachen die pflegeheime durch haben
und wenn man die über 80-jährigen
tatsächlich zeitnäher impfen können als
jetzt sage ich mal
april oder ende april mit unserer
impfzentren sich mit leben erfüllen ich
glaube dann wären wir hier vor ort schon
sehr sehr zufrieden vielen dank herr
busch das ende klingt schon weitaus
optimistischer als der anfang der
antwort da ging es um die
lebenswirklichkeit und ich übersetze das
jetzt mal der putsch hat eigentlich
gesagt sie sollen sich da nicht auch
ausreden denn da ist viel schief
gelaufen ersparen also erst einmal kenne
ich landrat pusch ja haus im beginnen
dieser pandemie als engagierten kämpfer
auch vor ort in der pandemie mit heinz
becker als erste betroffen
deswegen können wir uns auch gut
persönlich und ich schätze den austausch
ich schätze auch klare ansagen
aber ich bin eben genauso davon
überzeugt dass uns das in dieser phase
der pandemie nicht hilft wenn jetzt die
landräte auf die landesregierung
schimpfen die landesregierung
ministerpräsidenten auf die
bundesregierung die bundesregierung auf
die kommission und wir alle zusammen auf
die hersteller
das virus ist der feind das virus ist
der gegner und wir nicht untereinander
und deswegen bin ich sehr dafür
natürlich auch zu schauen was besser
werden muss
und ja terminvergabe verlässlichkeit in
den lieferung muss besser werden da gibt
es nichts drumherum zu reden da wir
schon sehr wichtig dass wir uns dabei in
dieser schwierigen phase auch unterhaken
und dass die dinge die aufzuarbeiten
sind natürlich gibt es dinge
aufzuarbeiten und zu lernen auch für die
zukunft aber die dann eben auch zur
gegebenen zeit aufgearbeitet werden in
dieser akuten phase der pandemie wo wir
in der schwersten phase sind auch fürs
land wir müssen ja sehen wir haben
einerseits die zeit der gegensätze
werden dem weg raus begonnen mit dem
impfen und wir sind immer noch in der
schwersten phase der partie
für deutschland und für europa in dieser
akuten phase finde ich jetzt eben sehr
sehr wichtig dass wir so wie herr prüft
das ja auch gesagt hat am ende seines
beitrages jetzt vor allem die dinge so
machen dass ich hab' ich verstehe dass
sie nicht nach hinten schauen wollen
denn da ist ja wahnsinnig viel schief
gelaufen und der putsch hat in der
vergangenheit auch gesagt zu den
eu-verträgen das hätte jeder landwirt
besser organisiert wie viel schuld
tragen sie an diesen schlechten
verträgen die damit der innerhalb der eu
zustande gekommen sind
zuerst einmal für nichts gut die eu
kommissionspräsident in frau von der
leyen die eu-kommission hat ja heute
auch ein weiteres spitzengespräch mit
den herstellern gehabt dass dort das
gespräch vor allem mit dem ziel gesucht
wird eben auch die kapazitäten jetzt
zügig zu erhöhen
aber das gilt ja für alles in dieser
pandemie mit dem wissen aus dem was
haben wir mit dem dreißigsten 31 januar
31 januar ist natürlich eine
entscheidung aus dem sommer immer besser
zu gewichten und zu bewerten und zu
besprechen als im sommer selbst ich kann
nur eins sagen ich weiß noch sehr genau
dass bis in den november hinein nahezu
jeder davon ausging dass ein impfstoff
frühestens 20 21 zur verfügung steht so
das ist gut dass es früher gekommen ist
das ist sogar eine riesen errungenschaft
der menschheit in dieser pandemie der
wissenschaft in dieser pandemie übrigens
mit bundesgeld und europäischem geld
gefördert ganz ohne die 700 millionen an
beyond ich und fuhr weg
und an andere hersteller wäre das
wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schnell
gelungen die der bund alleine gezahlt
hat in die forschung und in die
produktion hinein aber ich möchte bei
diesen sommer ganz kurz sprechen erst
bei an denn da gab es einen vertrag ein
brief den sie geschrieben haben der
exklusiv und bild enthüllt worden ist
wir wollen uns noch einmal anschauen wie
dieser brief aus sah nämlich so und wir
sehen da auch ihre unterschrift unter
diesen brief und da sollten sie so
wissen wir mit möglichst unterwürfigen
ton an von der leyen schreiben um
sozusagen diese im fall irans die sie
aufgebaut haben zurückzugeben an die eu
kommission
wenn sie sich jetzt noch mal die letzten
monate anschauen würden sie das wieder
machen
dass wir den europäischen weg gegangen
sind und wenig über die nein das ist
nicht meine frage doch würden sie werde
ich weder die allianz würden sie das
wieder abgeben ich komme ja den wenig
über die europäische union gehen
grundsätzlich ja aber ich bin wie ich
für richtig halte
würde man auf diesem weg wäre dann
gegangen worden ist aus heutiger sicht
manches anders machen sicherlich ohne
zweifel auch ja das eine ist ja nicht im
widerspruch zum anderen aber der ansatz
die europäisch das gemeinsam zu machen
in kroatien bulgarien in deutschland in
frankreich in dänemark gleichzeitig
beginnen zu können mit dem impfen den
gedanken dahinter halte ich weiterhin
für richtig wir kommen nur streitet
niemand ab regional ist gegen die anlage
zusammen aus ich es besser ist wenn viel
starke länder für die gesamte eu
verhandeln wenn die druck machen wenn
dort bekannte politiker für ihren
sparwillen sparen einstehen anders als
möglicherweise eben eine zypriotische eu
kommissarin die jetzt vielleicht nicht
die gleichen kontakte hat wie sie und
das sozusagen diese impf allianz dann am
ende bessere verträge für gesamteuropa
mal ob es besser gelaufen wäre wäre oder
nicht das lässt sich jetzt im nachhinein
ja nicht nicht beweisen es auch müßig
ist es hilft ja alles nichts also ich
verstehe ja ihr interesse an diesen
fragen ja ronzheimer ich hatte mich bis
sie ihn gedruckt haben an diesem brief
weil er für meine akute arbeit
ehrlicherweise wenig rolle spielt gar
nicht mehr erinnert er ist deswegen
geschrieben worden weil die
verhandlungen die wir geführt hatten ja
dann übergegangen sind in die
verhandlungen der europäischen union und
das musste er formal eben auch
entsprechend erfolgen so und der rest
ist dann passiert wäre passiert ist und
ich sage noch einmal das heißt nicht
dass da nicht die dinge aufgearbeitet
werden müssen und das heißt nicht dass
wir miteinander vor allem schauen müssen
wie auch entscheidungen bettes noch
einmal sein darf wenn die gleichen
maßstäbe und manchmal so gelten würde
die heute einige an die europäische
union und deren entscheidungswege legen
für den föderalismus in deutschland wird
es auch noch eine muntere debatte
es ist manchmal schon mühsam genug mit
16 bundesländern und einem bund
einheitlich eine linie zu finden und sie
übrigens dann auch einheitlich und
gemeinsam umzusetzen ist schon wieder
zwei paar schuhe
und genauso ist es mühsam man natürlich
mit 27 mitgliedstaaten und einer
europäischen union werden wir 4 1
da gewesenen dazu eine zuschauerfrage
denn wir haben 500 leserzuschriften
insgesamt bekommen
das thema bewegt die menschen und eine
davon geht genau um dieses thema welchen
anteil frei angela merkel an der
verzögerung bei der beschaffung des
impfstoffs und hätten sie schneller
gestellt wenn es keine intervention
gegeben hätte hätten sie schneller
bestellt wenn die kanzlerin nicht
interveniert hätte das möchte dieser
bild zuschauer wissen das ist ja so
keine kausalzusammenhang also zwischen
also erstmal gab es auch diese
intervention so nicht das ist aber auch
alles wie gesagt muss ich die frage ist
hätte schneller gehen können ohne
zweifel hätte es an bestimmten stellen
schneller gehen können und das gilt für
nationale prozesse die die gleiche
debatte hatten wir natürlich auch schon
bei der masken beschaffung hätte man
früher bestellen sollen im nachhinein ja
aber die krise ist deswegen auch eine
krise weil den dinge passieren auf die
wir nicht vorbereitet waren wir hätten
besser vorbereitet sein sollen das steht
doch außer frage
und das gleiche gilt jetzt auch ich bin
anders rum nicht per se der überzeugung
dass wenn wir früher die verträge
unterzeichnet hätten dass wir jetzt so
viel mehr impfstoff hätten aber die usa
haben wir haben früher angefangen die
grossbay also großbritannien hat besser
verhandelt da wo er aber im sommer klar
dass man nach bestellt warum haben sie
dann nicht mal als minister auf den
tisch gehauen und gesagt leute was sie
dann brüssel macht das ist zu lang
wir müssen jetzt handeln wir müssen
besser handel haben sie diese verträge
gar nicht gesehen
diesen monat wir haben uns ja
eingebrachte ich mich auch persönlich
überhaupt jetzt mal den vertrag mit
basel haben wir maßgeblichen anteil dass
er überhaupt in diesem volumen
stattgefunden war nicht viel mehr als
nur kurz mal sagen darf der pfizer chef
herr müller hat ja auch gesagt nach der
bestellung der eu das ist der grösste
direktbestellung vertrag den sie bisher
überhaupt abgeschlossen hatten weil etwa
die vereinigten staaten zwar optionen
auf 600 millionen dosen optionen
abgeschlossen hatten aber eben nicht
ich glaube nur 100 direkt bestellt
hatten und wir haben 300 millionen
direkt bestellt wir haben jetzt auch
weiter nach bestellt weil das finde ich
übrigens ganz wichtig weil ich manchmal
gefragt werde warum bestellte jetzt
eigentlich noch nicht dass kurz
erläutern darf weil wir ja nicht nur für
die erste und zweite impfung ausreichend
dosen brauchen
wir wissen ja gar nicht ob er
möglicherweise irgendwann auch eine
auffrischimpfung brauchen es gibt es ja
bei anderen impfungen auch dass man nach
einem jahr drei jahren fünf jahren noch
mal geimpft werden muss oder ob nicht
bestimmte mutationen die noch kommen
können gott sei dank bis jetzt noch
keine aber die noch kommen können ist
notwendig machen den impfstoff
anzupassen
und genau für diesen fall werden wir und
haben das auch schon getan wenn das noch
stärker tun auch impfdosen im
kapazitäten bis in das jahr 2022 hinein
sichern also wir werden auch weiter
zusätzlich bestellen
vorsorgen aber ersparen sie sind jemand
der über den tellerrand schaut sie
beschäftigen sich viel mit
großbritannien sie haben freunde in den
usa mussten doch im sommer gesehen haben
dass da irgendetwas schiefläuft
spätestens im herbst als dem
großbritannien schneller bestellt hat
als donald trump klar gemacht hat wir
bauen hier alles geld was wir haben so
ungefähr auf den tisch und die eu
knausert darum warum haben sie dann
nicht laut gesagt stopp wir müssen das
anders machen
wir haben doch dann die verträge auch
geschlossen wir haben mit 67 herstellern
verträge geschlossen weitere sind aber
längst nicht so gut aber die usa in
großbritannien
das weiß ich nicht die sind sie sehen
hier den anteil der geimpften ist das
ist so klein jetzt gerade an seht ja
offenkundig dass andere vor uns liegen
an der an der stelle ich will aber auch
noch mal sagen dass es sich um
unterschiedliche strategien zum teil
sind es die note zulassung ist eine
andere strategie das sind drei vier
wochen früher begonnen
das macht einen unterschied die
entscheidung entscheidung die man nicht
unterschätzen darf die hat nämlich
folgen die entscheidung die zweitimpfung
nach hinten zu schieben macht es jetzt
einigen ländern möglich schnell mehr
erstimpfungen zu machen aber wenn dann
lieferungen nicht kommen
dann gibt es eben problem weil wir aber
erst nicht dass wir hier als zur hälfte
durch werden wenn wir so schnell werden
wenn die usa dann wäre jetzt die hälfte
unserer bevölkerung gegen den usa ist
doch nicht die hälfte dabei nicht im
vergleich zu deutschland was heißt im
vergleich zu deutschen
in den usa sind was mittlerweile fast
über 30 40 millionen menschen geimpft
gut dass die usa natürlich insgesamt bei
einer größeren bevölkerung dann nochmal
auch andere maßstäbe haben ist klar so
wie wir das in relation zu israel eben
auch haben
ich tue mich auch schwer ich weiß jetzt
wenn sie wieder sagen typisch aber
trotzdem schwer mit diesen täglichen
vergleichen
die vergleich ziehen richtig gut wie
immer können nach zwei drei monaten wenn
wir auch schauen wie viele erste
impfungen sind erfolgt wie viele zweit
impfungen sind sind erfolgt wie sind
insbesondere die risikogruppen zuerst
geschützt
wie gut hat sich die organisation
eingespielt die usa haben wir auch das
würde ich jetzt nicht relativ wenig
beschreibt es nun mal auch ihre themen
in der umsetzung das ist die größte
impfkampagne in der geschichte der
menschheit aber warum hat wenig und
lässt wenig ungeimpfte sogar sagen weil
die usa ich tippe mal von moderner eben
tatsächlich schon mehr impfstoff haben
und das ist nicht ihr fehler dass
moderner in den usa sind ein dass auch
viel weniger haben was die anderen wir
haben das bestellt was möglich wäre mein
beispiel bringen beyonce hatten geplant
bis ende 2020 100 millionen dosen vor zu
produzieren dann gab's november dezember
in dem monatswechsel wenn ich richtig
erinnere die meldung die uns damals
schon ein stück zurückgeworfen hat in
unserer planung das wegen einer wegen
ausfällen sie am ende werden nur 50
millionen dosen four produzieren können
ist ein ziemlich gut für die welt ist
ein ziemlich großer unterschied und das
führt natürlich dazu dass dann auch die
anteile sich verringert haben hätte man
wenn man gewusst hätte dass war es
ausfällt früher noch mehr ersatzkapitän
ja klar aber dass das so in dem umfang
ausfällt hat doch keiner gesehen ich
bleibe erstmal weiterhin dabei dass wir
nach den auslieferungen die morgen
übermorgen erfolgen über vier millionen
dosen in deutschland ausgeliefert haben
werden die vererbt werden dass wir über
zwei prozent der bevölkerung geimpft
haben 70 prozent der bewohnerinnen und
bewohner einen pflegeeinrichtungen dass
es zug um zug immer mehr werden bei
allen problemen die besser werden müssen
jeden enttäuschungen die entstanden sind
ob die hotlines sind oder lieferungen
die ausgefallen sind
aber das nicht gleichzeitig auch was
passiert ist und nicht eben auch viele
menschen schon den schutz erreicht haben
ich finde das darf man dabei nicht auch
vergessen dass das sind viele menschen
für sie in deutschland im vergleich zu
30 millionen in den usa
es sind erst mal zwei prozent der
bevölkerung bei der wir natürlich wird
es jeden tag mehr ich hätte auch lieber
schon zehn prozent geimpft ist überhaupt
nicht die frage
aber ich wissen
am ende funktioniert das doch nur wenn
wir realistisch miteinander sind
übrigens mit blick auf den auf den
gipfel auf das treffen morgen
wir können wir können durch einen gipfel
allein nicht mehr im stoffe produzieren
impfstoffproduktion ist das
anspruchsvollste was es gibt da gibt es
auch sehr um qualität wir kämpfen da ja
etwas an gesunde menschen wird injiziert
das heißt also die qualität muss bei
jedem schritt stimmen und jede charge
jedes produkt wird noch mal geprüft so
richtig so weil höchste anforderungen
wichtig sind für vertrauen und deswegen
geht das nicht in drei oder fünf wochen
also ich finde wir müssen jetzt auch mit
blick auf den gipfel realistisch bleiben
vor allem ist mir wichtig dass wir ein
einheitliches bild kriegen
ich verstehe wenn gesagt wird der bund
muss verbindliche lieferdaten geben aber
wir sitzen ja nicht irgendwie auf daten
die wir irgendwie nicht weitergehen so
dass michael müller heute zu einem
online-brief ja auch andere er ist ja
nicht so dass wir irgendwie die daten
verheimlichen wir können am ende nur die
liefermengen und daten den ländern mit
teilen die wir von den herstellern
bekommen und die geben wir auch direkt
weiter und ich wäre ich bin einfach
dankbar die hersteller werden am morgen
dabei sein wenn dann noch mal auch
erläutert und dargelegt wird warum im
moment jedenfalls bei der produktion die
er nicht auf lager geht sondern direkt
alles was produziert wird geht raus und
bei jedem kleinen dingen das passiert
können verzögerungen entstehen wenn das
einfach noch mal miteinander besprochen
und erläutert wird wenn wir auskunft
erhalten wie verbindlich in zukunft
geplant werden kann
aber eins bleibt dem auch war dadurch
dass jeden tag jemand ist sagt es muss
schneller gehen wird produktion person
noch nicht schneller sondern wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass es sich um
kooperationen entstehen wo es schneller
geht es waren und wo zumindest ich
neidisch hinschaue sie sagen bei uns ist
doch irgendwie alles gut aber ich schaue
neidisch zuerst habe ich so nur zum
festhalten so nicht und wenn wir das das
war es überspitzt vor mir das ist
richtig aber ich schaue neidisch in die
usa zumindest wo mein kollege herbert
bauernebel vor einem impfzentrum steht
herbert wie viele menschen hast du
gezielt in den letzten minuten die dort
rein sind und so sehnlich auf den
impfstoff gewartet haben
ja ich stehe hier vor dem jobcenter in
new york city das ist ein normaler weise
ein messer zentrum wurde auch
weltberühmt damals während der caron
alle im frühjahr als es umgebaut wurde
in ein feldlazarett
und jetzt ist es eben eines dieser
großen impfzentren in new york und man
sieht ja hinter mir das ist sehr gut
organisiert in der halle
hier sieht man die schalter wo die leute
dann wo die leute dann einchecken und
vor dem gebäude gibt es keinen richtigen
hochbetrieb aber doch einen steten strom
an menschen hier zum beispiel sieht man
drüben geht gerade eine frau hinein
das ganze ist organisiert mit terminen
natürlich deshalb gibt es auch hier
keine langen warteschlangen
aber man sieht jetzt wirklich in den
letzten stunde wo wir hier waren das
hier sicher so 100 150 leute rein
gegangen sind viele ältere menschen die
gruppe die jetzt dran ist hier in new
york ist jene die von menschen älter als
65 und auch essentielle berufe wie zb
cops oder oder lehrer und die können
termine jetzt machen und man sieht hier
wird geimpft 800.000 menschen in new
york city sind bereits geimpft
das einzige problem auch hier in den usa
es wird langsam dass der impfstoff der
nachschub knapp
herr sind dann herbert letzte frage zu
dem komplex usa jens spahn warum hat
denn donald trump den viele so verachten
hier in deutschland das so gut
hinbekommen es war zuerst einmal die
baader das ist eine institution in den
vereinigten staaten die auch tatsächlich
mit vielen finanziellen mittel nicht nur
in dieser krise sondern insgesamt dass
tatsächlich ein anderer ansatz von denen
wir lernen können in europa die
europäische kommission hat den vorschlag
er heißt ein herr in der abkürzung auch
schon gemacht dass wir in institutionen
haben die die geld hat die innovationen
finanzieren kann die nicht gebunden ist
es war ja auch ein thema durchaus was
was es so lange hat werden lassen in den
verhandlungen an themen allen bereichen
des vergaberechts des haftungsrechts ich
meine wir müssen immer sehr in den usa
und großbritannien hat der staat die
haftung fast vollständig von den
unternehmen genommen wir haben in europa
eine tradition die bei jemandem der was
produziert auch wenn sein leben stoff
ist schon auch eine haftung beim
hersteller sieht übrigens das
europäische parlament hat sehr kritisch
in jeder phase der debatte eingefordert
dass diese haftung auch bei den
herstellern bleibt so dass sind andere
voraussetzungen
und deswegen haben mit diesem institut
bada diese abkürzung aber dieses diese
institutionen die eben
das geld hat die schnell entscheidet die
dann auch mitgeholfen hat gerade auch
bei moderner so etwas braucht europa die
europäische union auch schnelle
entscheidungen viele hoffen auf den
morgigen impfgipfel sie sagen da wird
jetzt nicht einfach schneller impfstoff
produziert aber warum gibt es dann
diesen gipfel und was ganz konkret wird
für die menschen in deutschland dadurch
besser zuerst einmal finde ich es
wichtig auch nach den letzten zwei drei
wochen und den diskussionen die
öffentlich statt gefunden haben dass wir
einfach mal miteinander reden wieder
mehr zwischen bund und ländern und mit
den herstellern weil wie gesagt dieses
dieses spiel
jeder schiebt zum anderen das hilft uns
jetzt nicht weiter sondern müssen wir
gemeinsam schauen wie es die lage wo
stehen wir
was ist nicht gut gewesen in den letzten
monaten was haben wir zusammen erreicht
wo können und müssen wir besser werden
welchen teil können wir auch als bund
dazu beitragen was könnte das noch nicht
in seinen opern produktion premiere was
schwebt ihnen persönlich produktions
frage der themen gehabt auch dabei
bleiben was mal so wird jetzt die zwangs
lizenz zum beispiel wieder ein vorschlag
gebracht eine zwangs lizenz macht er nur
dann sinn wenn die unternehmen von sich
aus nicht kooperieren würden das tun sie
aber ja schauen sie mal nur die letzten
zwei wochen bei lonza hat angekündigt
mit seinen notizen zu arbeiten 100
millionen impfstoffe zusätzlich
schneller in die abfüllung zu bringen in
den nächsten monaten bayern angekündigt
mit novartis zusammenzuarbeiten zur
produktion mit baxter in halle ein
unternehmen zur abfüllung das werk in
marburg hat die genehmigung erhalten
kühe weg wir mit der bayer ag
kooperieren um dinge auch schneller
vorantreiben zu können
die idee übrigens sind deshalb auch eine
perle der impfstoff produktion und
abfüllung kooperiert mit astra zyniker
mit anderen unternehmen die vorprodukte
hersteller übrigens auch ganz wichtig
wie evonik oder mehr quorum lipide und
andere vorprodukte für impfstoffe geht
alle kooperieren aber was ist er herr
fuß sagt zum beispiel sind die konkreten
fragen die hersteller sollen prämien
kriegen für frühe ich hatte gerade mit
einem c o eines unternehmens telefoniert
quasi auf dem weg hierhin habe ihn
gefragt gibt es irgendetwas was wir mit
geld beschleunigen können antwort war
nein
es ist im moment kein geld thema sondern
ein thema das die bioreaktoren also das
was andrack substance und druck
ein medikament nehmen stoff substanz
entsteht das braucht seine 23 monate
wenn jetzt also neue reaktoren
aufgestellt werden und genutzt werden
manche umgewidmet werden für diesen
impfstoff dann dauert ist trotzdem die
zwei monate bis entsprechend der
wirkstoff dha da rauskommt und ich habe
schon mehrfach die jeweiligen
vorstandsvorsitzenden die unternehmen
die forscher gefragt können wir mit geld
in dieser phase scheitert wird ja nicht
am geld scheitern wenn mir jemand sagt
ich liefert dir in zwei wochen eine
impfstoff für das geld dann sind wir ja
dabei aber scheitert im moment eben
nicht am geld sondern es scheitert eben
daran spannend der situation wer soll
das verstehen wochen lang haben sie sich
erklärte gerade aber gewehrt jetzt haben
sie denn auf druck der opposition oder
der opposition innerhalb der regierung
die spd haben sie sich dafür entschieden
das zu machen wenn sie jetzt am morgen
stehen da können sie doch nicht
ernsthaft sagen wir haben eigentlich wir
wissen eigentlich nicht was wir besser
machen sollen aber wir haben das habe
ich ja nicht gesagt herr uns zuerst
einmal warum auch ich am ende gesagt
habe es macht sinn sich zusammenzusetzen
zwischen bund und ländern mit den
herstellern ist weil das so auseinander
gelaufen ist auch in der in der
kommunikation und dem wie wir
miteinander übereinander reden
das wichtigste in dieser pandemie ist
vertrauen auch beim impfen ist das
vertrauen wichtig und wir haben schon
beim beherbergung beherbergungs verbot
gesehen wenn wir nicht einheitlich
agieren geht vertrauen gern schnell
verloren und ich möchte einfach
vermeiden dass das jetzt beim impfen
auch passiert und deswegen ist das schon
ein wert an sich
dass wir gemeinsam also erst mal
miteinander feststellen haben wir
gemeinsam blick auf die lage und wenn
nein wie kommen wir da hin haben ein
gemeinsames verständnis davon wie die
nächsten zwei drei monate werden auch
beim impfen
ich sage ihnen jetzt schon es werden
noch zehn wochen auf der knappheit harte
wochen für uns werden es wird zug um zug
besser aber es wird eine ganze zeit lang
noch knapp sein
und natürlich wollen wir schauen mit den
herstellern erst mal warum ist das so
schwierig aber auch zweitens wo können
wir noch unterstützen wo können wir
helfen aber ihre frage gerade eben war
ja
könnten wir mit finanziellen anreizen
einen unterschied machen
nach allem was mir bis jetzt die
hersteller sagen ist geld im moment
nicht das thema dass es schneller macht
wenn das morgen raus kommen sollte
werden wir das natürlich machen also mit
der bitte um kurze antwort durch den
gipfel morgen wird nichts besser
doch ok aber was können sie mir nicht
genau sagen
doch dass wir erst einmal ein
gemeinsames verständnis haben ein
einheitliches agieren ein einheitliches
kommen also das ist nicht mehr so viel
ministerpräsidenten sie kritisieren am
ende oder weil das ist ein wert an sich
das können sie jetzt so sehen oder nicht
so sehen ich finde es ist in dieser
pandemie ein wert an sich dass bund und
länder gemeinsam agieren ein gemeinsames
verständnis von der lage haben ein
gemeinsames ziel haben die gemeinsamen
realistischen blick haben auf das was
geht und was nicht geht und sich auch
gemeinsam morgen erstmal nachdem sie
sich ein bild von der lage verschafft
haben übrigens muss man ja nicht morgen
gleicht sofort alles beschließen wir
können ja auch morgen mit den
herstellern erst mal miteinander
erörtern und erfahren was noch besser
geht und dann werden wir uns ja schon
zeitnah wieder treffen bund und länder
jetzt eben auch die zeitnahe im februar
um ja über den weiteren verlauf auch
beim lockdown zu reden und dann können
wir auch gemeinsam schlüsse ziehen
ich finde es trotzdem wichtig mit den
herstellern mit den ländern mit dem bund
zusammen zu reden und zu einer
einheitlichen einschätzung und maßnahmen
sie sprechen über vertrauen ich möchte
ihnen einmal zeigen was der göttinger
polizeipräsident zum thema vertrauen
beim impfstoff gesagt hat dass meine
mutter hat im januar auf einem brief
gewartet dass sie sich endlich zum
impfen anmelden kann
sie hat dann einen brief bekommen
allerdings adressiert an meinen vater
der bereits am 22 november verstorben
ist hat reingeguckt und hat sich
gewundert dass er die aufforderung hatte
sich am 28
zum impfen anzumelden und hat auch bis
heute gewartet dass hier auch noch einen
brief bekommt aber hat keinen bekommen
ich kann nur sagen das was ich auch aus
meinem bekanntenkreis und aus der
nachbarschaft reis höre dass man eben
dieses vertrauen verloren hat
ich bin kein querdenker ich habe alle
maßnahmen mitgemacht ich achte auch
darauf dass die kontakt beschränkung
eingehalten werden ich bin der erste
mitmacht
dumm gelaufen ist aber ich erwarte jetzt
auch das land die impfungen beginnen und
zwar auf strukturiert und nach einem
system ersparen
das hat es noch nie gegeben dass ein
polizeipräsident öffentlich sagt er hat
das vertrauen verloren am ende in den
start
wie gehen sie damit um ich habe jetzt
hellhörig so verstanden dass das vor
allem eben auch aus seiner perspektive
als als bürger als sohn seiner mutter
auch geschrieben hat und das ist ja
total nachvollziehbar dass natürlich der
wunsch da ist die ungeduld ein stück
frust natürlich auch mit dem was bei den
hotlines passiert ist nicht überall aber
doch an manchen stellen nämlich lange
wartezeiten
das die erwartung ist dass das besser
wird und die erwartung haben wir ja auch
gemeinsam aber eins bleibt halt und ich
finde da bin ich jetzt auch ehrlich und
realistisch solange dieser impfstoff
knapp ist und das wird noch einige
wochen so seiden werden wir eben nur
nach und nach ein angebot machen können
das muss so strukturiert wie es eben
geht natürlich laufen das muss
nachvollziehbar sein wer wann warum ein
angebot erhält und das ist tatsächlich
im moment in den 16 bundesländern 16 mal
unterschiedlich gelöst das war glaube
ich nie dagegen genau niedersachsen hat
einen anderen weg gewählt als
schleswig-holstein wenn sie mich jetzt
fragen warum gibt 16 unterschiedliche
wege
weil am ende eben dass der wunsch der 16
länder war und ob sie es glauben oder
nicht nach der verfassungsmäßigen
ordnung die wir hatten ja vorhin schon
mal ist in einer pandemie die haupt
zuständigkeit tatsächlich bei den
ländern
und wir übernehmen aufgaben vor allem
eben auch da wo länder mit uns
vereinbaren dass wir sie übernehmen das
finde ich auch sehr wichtig weil es ein
großes bedürfnis und notwendigkeit nach
bundeseinheitlich kite gibt aber in dem
moment wo eben 16 länder sagen den teil
wollen wir alleine organisieren zb die
terminvergabe ist das dann so sie
sprechen die zeit an viel zeit hat kim
zierold nicht weil er verzweifelt auf
einen impfstoff wartet und sich
vergessen fühlen erzählt sie erleben
diese debatte momentan sie sitzen mit
muskelschwäche im rollstuhl müssen eine
art
maske getragen und bekommen keine
impfung bislang wie viel angst haben sie
vor corona und was sollte die politik
was sollte hier einsparen aus ihrer
sicht tun
also ich habe dadurch unter anderem die
pflegekraft zu dichtet
ich vermute ich eine kuh roulette so
richtig verdient werde
er tötet sie dass sie sorgt das bett ich
so schnell wie möglich die erste hat
körpern ersparen was können sie tun wie
können sie ganz persönlich helfen
das ist ja das ziel auch menschen die
eine vorerkrankung haben wir jetzt hier
rollt und die natürlich nachvollziehbar
sehr große sorge haben sich zu
infizieren weil das risiko natürlich
damit ein großes ist auch
schnellstmöglich zu impfen und
gleichzeitig bleibt eben das problem
dass wir im moment nicht ausreichend
impfstoff haben um alle die tatsächlich
ein erhöhtes risiko haben gleichzeitig
wurde jetzt in den ersten wochen zu
impfen
und jetzt ist das wie naja wie in der
gesellschaft wie in der familie wir
müssen jetzt gerade ein knappes gut
verteilen und dann ist sozusagen in der
familie die die die großmutter da die 83
jährige mit einem risiko ist vielleicht
eine tochter in der familie erzieherin
mit einem risiko im berufsalltag
es gibt vielleicht jemanden der familien
mit einer sehr schweren vorerkrankung
und jetzt hat man halt eine dose man
weiß man wird alle impfen können in den
nächsten wochen aber heute steht nur
eine dose zur verfügung bei hätte sicher
ist nicht mal in der prioritätenliste
auf platz eins oder zwei er kommt wenn
es so weiter geht erst in monaten ist
das gerät der vorerkrankung und dass ich
jetzt das krankheitsbild und detail
kenne wäre es nach meiner einschätzung
priorisierung gruppe 2 aber das ist ja
eine frage die haben das ist ja ich will
dass nur noch mal erläutern das ist eine
total schwere frage es ist es in der
familie in so einer situation wenn würde
man dann impfen und das ist weil
natürlich jeder ich doch auch sofort
intuitiv sagen würde erzählte sie
sollten eigentlich jetzt sofort ihre
impfung bekommen
das ist klar dass das sofort intuitiv
doch nach licht wenn das risiko da ist
und gleichzeitig müssen wir es ja
irgendwie versuchen jedenfalls so
gerecht wie möglich zu machen deswegen
haben wir die ständige impfkommission
gebeten auf basis von risikoanalysen im
zu sagen wo ist das risiko am größten
und das risiko wenn sie jetzt mal die
gesamtbevölkerung nehmen ist bei den
über 80 jährigen und dem
pflegebedürftigen wenn wir das
ausbruchsgeschehen am größten aber
individuell natürlich dann doch da was
es geben kann
das haben wir ja auch schon gesehen sind
einzelfall entscheidungen zu einer
situation die sozusagen von so einer
generellen für alle gültigen reihenfolge
gar nicht getroffen oder oder abgebildet
sein können
aber ja es ist eine recht schwierige
situation doch schwierig das plausibel
und verständlich zu machen warum jetzt
die einen früher dran sind als die
anderen aber bei dieser knappheit müssen
wir eben am ende nach bestimmten
kriterien entscheiden
herr zierold sie haben gehört was der
minister zu ihrem fall gesagt hat und so
prioritätenliste stellt sie das
zufrieden
das ist schon seit wochen versuche eine
einzelfallentscheidung
da war ich doch dieser tracks nicht
weiter capture die band eingespielt bis
zum präsidenten eingespielt und er
bekommt eine weitere der etwa oder
vielen vielen dank
wir können eines versprechen von bild
wir werden uns dafür einsetzen werden an
allen stellen in niedersachsen auch
nachfragen was da passiert ist und warum
sie keine antwort bekommen herzlichen
dank dennoch die frage nochmal man sich
sparen wenn sie das hören das kann doch
nicht wahr sein oder das heißt es kann
doch nicht wahr sein es ist die
situation in der wir gerade sind
jeder ich genauso wie sie würde am
liebsten sagen jetzt hier rollt
natürlich kriegen sie morgen ihre
impfung in der schwierigen situation in
der sie sind mit den sorgen die sie
haben müssen die jeder sieht die jeder
nachvollziehen kann und gleichzeitig ist
es im moment knapp und deswegen müssen
wir am ende ja irgendwie entscheidend
und wie gesagt das machen wir auf basis
der ständigen impfkommission der
empfehlung die eben das interesse daran
natürlich das mal sagen darf auf seiten
des robert koch instituts etwa 70 seiten
eben hergeleitet hat die risiken und wo
wir anfangen sollten wollte auch das
risiko für die gruppe sozusagen der über
80-jährigen am größten ist und dann
kommt das einzelschicksal dazu und das
macht es ja so schwer dass das dann auch
immer wieder zu erläutern und zu
erörtern
das gilt übrigens auch für die
einzelfallentscheidung wenn ich das so
sagen darf auch ich verstehe auch da
natürlich dass viele sagen aber meine
individuelle situation da bitte ich noch
einmal um eine prüfung aber das können
natürlich die landesbehörden auch schwer
schaffen wenn jetzt auf einmal zwei oder
vier millionen menschen oder mehr eine
einzelfallentscheidung für sich erbitten
aus nachvollziehbaren gründen nicht
falsch verstehen aber dann ist das
natürlich irgendwann kaum noch zu händen
und deswegen ist die lösung die einzig
wirklich gute lösung ist ja dass wir zu
mehr impfstoff kommen das ist ja unser
hauptziel bleibt auch unser hauptziel es
wird auch woche um woche mehr werden
aber es ist jetzt eben noch eine phase
dieser knappheit bei der wir weiterhin
das ist übrigens der ganz wichtige teil
auch einfach aufeinander aufpassen
müssen die aha regeln ich weiß manche
können es gar nicht mehr hören aber auch
jetzt wenn wir begonnen haben zum impfen
solange wir nicht eine gewisse gewissen
schutz für die gesamtgesellschaft und
damit für viele einzelne erreicht haben
werden wir weiterhin
sehr aufeinander aufpassen müssen an ein
ende sozusagen ist absehbar aber das
dauert noch ein paar monate und da kann
ich einfach nur auch bitten
für uns alle für die mit vorerkrankungen
und für die ohne dass wir weiterhin acht
geben sie sagen es dauert noch ein paar
monate die krone pandemie ist jetzt fast
oder ist genau ein jahr her in
deutschland der erste fall rund ein jahr
her und wir haben mal zurück geschaut
und einen fall gefunden von christian
wimmer einem arzt der mit ihnen bei
maybrit illner in einer talkshow saß
also dass wir sie so ganz banal und
jetzt sagen sie ersparen wir in
deutschland sind gut vorbereitet haben
unsere behörden haben unsere
krankenhäuser schon mal einen solchen
stresstest vergleichbar derzeit zu china
bestanden hat der erste der mir ein
viele wow effekt zum beispiel wo wir
auch ganz andere zusammenhänge am ende
aber aus lebensmitteln jahr nach
deutschland und mit lebensmittel nach
deutschland gekommen aber die situation
ja hatten vor etwa zehn jahren und das
war ja auch ein stresstest für für uns
alle ist als entscheidende deswegen sind
wir gut vorbereitet ist schnell die
infektionskette zu unterbrechen und
gesundheitswesen wie unseres kaders
momentan haben wir einfach wirklich das
glück auf unserer seite
das kann ganz schnell kippen aber ich
finde es auch wichtig weil wir haben
jetzt gerade 14 55 der infektion haben
gerade die nadel gemälde sind den
zuschauer nochmals heran eine fünfte
infektion die auch mit dem gerade
gezeigten webasto
falls die situation zusammen hängt und
die vier jedenfalls die wir schon hatten
die sind im moment symptomfrei die sind
sagte der behandelnde arzt in der
pressekonferenz putzmunter
das ist nichts was man eben ab tun kann
sondern das ist ich finde ein wirklich
großes problem wo man auch jetzt noch
gar nicht sagen kann das wird schon so
und zu sein
das kann in alle richtungen gehen hatte
er immer mehr recht als sie damals
verschwand ja hat er offenkundig eine
einschätzung
wo auch viele sich ergeben hat daraus
und gleichzeitig will sie das ist ja
alles klar würde ich zwölf monate später
die dinge an bestimmten stellen auch
anders sehen und formulieren es mag
vielleicht sogar ein kommentar von paul
ronzheimer geben in der bild den er
heute anders schreiben würde als er in
vier sechs oder zwölf monaten
geschrieben hat ich weiß nicht ob sie
immer richtig lagen in den letzten zwölf
monaten aber mit den informationen die
wir damals hatten wir hatten ja
sozusagen nur gesehen wenn es einmal
erinnert webasto war gerade in
unternehmen wo es die ersten
infektionsfälle gab in deutschland das
waren richtig erinnere 30 bis 50
jährigen etwa wollen so ein ding
einspielen aber wir wollen herrn will
man mit ihr zu nehmen da er sonst
nämlich zugeschaltet er will man als die
am 7
denn wenigstens mein gedanke war sollte
nicht nur das zunehmend kurz hallo herr
wilmar schön sie wiederzusehen langer
zeit aber jedenfalls jetzt haben sie mir
ein bisschen ein konzept absolute damals
hatten wir die situation tatsächlich in
deutschland dass die infizierten die wir
hatten halt überhaupt nicht risikogruppe
waren und das was wir gesehen haben
einen krankheitsverlauf und so herr
professor rentner denen sie gerade der
ja auch gerade zitiert worden ist der
hatte tatsächlich das sagt er selber ja
auch damals eine andere einschätzung als
schon wenige monate später also wir
haben das alle von anfang an ernst
genommen aber dass sich das daraus so
entwickelt das habe ich jedenfalls nicht
erwartet und vorhergesehen das muss ich
auch so sagen herr wimmer sie haben
gehört dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister hier gesagt
hat was geht in ihnen vor wenn sie die
bilder und ihre aussagen von damals
hören und wenn sie die aktuelle debatte
hier verfolgen
also ich finde erst mal das hat größe
das ersparen das sagt man schätzt dinger
halt anders ein
ich habe es ganz klar
sehen weil ich auch in china gearbeitet
und gelebt habe ich freue mich natürlich
bisschen was hätte ich besser machen
können in der situation um herrn sparen
zu überzeugen
für mich ist nicht nur das problem dass
ersparen das damals nicht gehört hat und
daraus natürlich die konsequenzen
schnell genug entstanden sind
es war auch medial schwierig ja am
nächsten tag hat der große minister den
kleinen jungen mediziner sozusagen
abgewatscht stellen und das wird dann
auch dementsprechend geschrieben dann
schreibt ein medium von anderen ab das
hat sich die bild sondern das waren halt
er so im redaktionelle netzwerke und da
muss man sagen das ist dann schon
wirklich komplex und und auch nicht gut
was mich grad an der diskussion bisschen
stört und das erinnert mich an damals
ist wir sprechen viel zu viel über das
entgegen krippe mumps masern röteln
können wir auch impfen
viel wichtiger ist doch jetzt noch mehr
in die therapie im ambulanten bereich zu
gehen das heißt wenn eine 72 jährige
dame ja die sind schon mit druck auf der
brust zu hause da ist nichts ihr
hausarzt kann hier nichts anbieten sie
wartet zu hause weiß gar nicht ob es
rechts oder links geht dann schafft sie
es irgendwie oder geht sie auf die
intensivstation also da muss einfach
wesentlich mehr passieren oder welche
auch sehr gespannt ersparen was da
konkret gemacht wird herr wimmer vielen
dank gleichzeitig haben sie uns von
einem fall berichtet ihrer verstorbenen
tochter darüber haben wir in den
vergangenen wochen berichtet wo es auch
um die frage geht wie ist in deutschland
um die behörden steht und was dort
eigentlich schief läuft erzählen sie uns
noch einmal wie es ihnen ergangen ist
und ja warum sie da auch etwas wütend
macht na ja das problem ist halt eben
wenn sie als ganz normaler bürger zu
hause sitzen und sie kriegen immer
wieder briefe und warte natürlich auch
auf diese noch auf jenes und dann kommt
ein brief von der bundesregierung an die
kürzlich verstorbene oder gar kürzlich
über zwei monaten voll verstorbene
tochter dass sie nun masken bekommen
kann sie hätte ein recht dafür gehabt
aufgrund der schwere ihrer behinderung
und dann ist das unterschrieben mit
ihrer wunden bleiben sie gesund ihre
bundesregierung
da muss man sagen das ist einfach
handwerklich schlecht also dass das löst
bei mir viele schlechte gefühle auslöst
erlöst auch gut aus und seitdem die bild
darüber berichtet läuft mein postfach
überall so dms ist häufig ich habe
hunderte von zuschriften
kommen wo leute genau das gleiche sagen
der polizeipräsident hat sie quasi
ähnlicher weise gesagt also das kleine
einmaleins der daten bewältigung ich
glaube da ist sehr viel aufholbedarf und
dass das machen wir jetzt mal als
normaler bürger nicht als mediziner er
sondern das macht mich das schon auch
ein bisschen traurig da hätte ich von
deutschland mehr aber es waren warum
läuft da bei dem brief so viel schief
zuerst einmal kann ich nur
entschuldigung sagen ich kann nur
ansatzweise ermessen wie viel schmerz
das auslöst ich kann mich erinnern dass
schwiegervater verstarb gab es auch viel
zu lange noch briefe von institutionen
die neben nicht wussten dass er
verstorben ist und jedes mal tut das weh
und in so einer situation über ein
wimmer tut es natürlich ganz besonders
weh doch alles noch so frisch und und
präsent ist und gleichzeitig um so weit
zu erklären dass entschuldigt es nicht
um es vorweg zu nehmen ist erklärt es
nur ist natürlich so dass es einen
stichtag gibt den wir nehmen mussten wir
irgendein tag nehmen
sozusagen den datensatz von dem tag an
die krankenkassen in unserem auftrag
genommen um 34 millionen menschen in
deutschland an zu schreiben
und wenn sozusagen zwischen diesem
stichtag und dem versand der briefe sich
dann eben was in diesem fall sehr
tragisch ergeben hat dann ist der brief
trotzdem versandt worden weil dessen
ganz dass eine ganze eigene sendung wird
digitale verwaltung in deutschland die
frage wann die meldung einer geburt
eines todesfalls veränderungen in den
umständen tatsächlich bei allen behörden
und institutionen da sind aber dadurch
entsteht dass ich will übrigens auch
weil er einige kriegt ja auch nicht auf
dem mond lebt ja auch von meinem
bekannten und verwandten rückmeldung was
diesen brief angeht und meinen 34
millionen menschen heißt ja irgendwie
jeder kennt einen der ein krieg dich ja
schon logik der sache bei 80 millionen
einwohnern dann kommt die frage warum
habe ich eine eigentlich eingekriegt und
wir haben das ja gemacht nach bestimmten
vorerkrankungen die sozusagen definiert
worden sind von fachleuten was sind
risiken für eine mögliche bei einer
möglichen infektion für einen bestimmten
verlauf und dann haben wir überlegt wer
hat überhaupt das wissen darüber
gebündelt wer solche vorerkrankungen hat
und da gibt es natürlich andere keiner
aus meiner sicht jedenfalls keine
anderen institutionen als die
krankenkassen die das da
60 gebündelt vorliegen haben und die
gehen dann natürlich nach denen daten
nach denen diagnosen die ihnen
mitgeteilt worden sind die abgerechnet
worden sind von den ärzten beispiel
jemand hatte letztes jahr an asthma
anfall oder ein verdacht madonnen
verdacht gewesen sein auf einer
asthma-erkrankung dann wurde
entsprechend was abgerechnet und dann
ist das erst mal bei der krankenkasse
entsprechend vermerkt und dann wurde
eben an die betreffende person die im
zweifel gesund und munter ist aber
aufgrund dieses verdachtes der
briefversand ist das perfekt nein eine
bessere lösung gehabt es so schnell zu
machen also ich kenne keine wenn jemand
eine bessere gehabt hätte nehme ich
nehme ich den hinweis gerne aber wir
haben ihm den weg gesucht mit dem wir
das schnellstmöglich auch tatsächlich
umsetzen können wenn jetzt jemand sagt
ich krieg so eine maske weiß gar nicht
warum dann hat das was damit zu tun dass
bei der krankenkasse oder
krankenversicherung eine entsprechende
information durch eine abrechnung von
möglicherweise einem arzt eben
hinterlegtes masken impfen briefe wir
sind
wir hören dass sie insbesondere von der
beratungsagentur immer wieder beraten
werden auch was schritte angeht die man
unternimmt ist diese agentur die falsche
muss man das mal so klar benennen also
bei der frage wie wir eine verordnung
für masken machen ist keine wahl
beteiligt
aber bei anderen fragen die sie in den
vergangenen monaten beschäftigt haben
und wohlstand immer wieder in der kritik
auch als agentur
also ist hinzugezogen worden tatsächlich
für die ist aber ein anderes masken
thema nicht geht es ja um die
beschaffung vor einem jahr in etwa zu
der zeit wo wir den sendungs ausschnitt
gesehen haben war ja auch die zeit wo
masken begannen sehr knapp zu werden auf
dem weltmarkt wo wir das getan haben was
sie bei impfstoffen einfordern nämlich
flexibel und schnell und losgelöst vom
vergaberecht und vielen vorgaben und es
gibt das vergaberecht herrin in einer
solchen notlage einfach schnell
entschieden haben
helmut schmidt mäßig quasi gekauft haben
aber natürlich dabei auch gesagt haben
die qualitätsanforderungen müssen schon
passen weil das sind masken wie gehen an
die pflegekräfte an die ärztinnen und
ärzte die müssen schützen so wir sind
dann auch beliefert weil wir haben ja
dann ausreichend masken auch besorgen
können den ländern liefern können den
krankenhäusern liefern können
heute ist die situation völlig anders
mittlerweile gibt es die masken für ich
weiß nicht welchen preis zum teil sogar
im discounter aber das war damals anders
sollte um das aufzuarbeiten und das zu
begleiten
da hat tatsächlich das bundesministerium
für gesundheit alleine eben auch
unterstützung gebraucht und da haben wir
tatsächlich eben eine entsprechende
beratung mit dazugenommen ersparen die
menschen beschäftigt natürlich nicht nur
die frage was mit dem impfstoff schief
gegangen ist wie das jetzt schneller
läuft sondern vor allem auch die frage
natürlich daran hängt auch ein bisschen
wie lang es jetzt mit dem lockdown
weitergeht und wie lange sie denn noch
mal verlängern wollen wie lange wird das
passieren und gehören sie zu denjenigen
die sagen wir müssen das noch weit über
den 14 februar hinaus machen
zuerst einmal weil sie stellen fest ich
versuche immer auch auf die positiven
dinge zu schauen nicht um irgendwie rosa
brille zu haben sondern weil ich es
wichtig finde im leben auch
wahrzunehmen was erreicht wird ist mein
blick auf die welt was wir erreicht
haben und dann zu schauen was wir noch
besser machen können gut zusammen beides
aber was wir erreicht haben zusammen ist
ja erst mal dass die zahlen gesunken
sind und ich finde dass erstmal sehr
ermutigend weil uns das zum zweiten mal
zeigt nach der früher wir können
zusammen diesen unterschied machen und
wir kriegen die infektionszahlen die
sehr hoch gewesen sind runter und sie
singen sie sinken auf den infektion auf
den intensivstationen langsamer muss man
aber sie sinken das erstmal ermutigen
dabei sind noch nicht so tief dass wir
stand heute ein dreißigstel januar schon
abschließend sagen können ich meine sind
jetzt auch noch zwei wochen und wir
haben den letzten zwei wochen gesehen
wie die entwicklung war
ich kann noch nicht sagen wie die zahlen
im zehnten februar sind wie sich das bis
dahin entwickelt und deswegen sind wir
heute noch in der situation dass wir auf
jeden fall sein müssen wir brauchen
diesen blog da und die nächsten tage
noch die nächsten zwei wochen noch so
lockt ein ende nicht mitte februar die
nächsten zwei wochen ist jetzt exakt
mitte februar 14 februar und dann müssen
wir schauen eben paar tage vorher wo
stehen wir wir sind die zahlen welche
maßnahmen sind weiter notwendig kann man
ob und wenn ja welche lockerungsschritte
gehen und ich bin von einem zutiefst
überzeugt dass wenn wir sie gehen wir
zuerst auch im bereich von kita und
grundschule anfangen müssen also sind
lockerungen optionen für sie dann
es hängt von den zahlen ab und wie weit
müssen die runter die kanzlerin spricht
immer wieder sehr freundlich zu mir
gesagt wichtig nicht zu früh bei zu
vielen dingen fest in der sache wie so
dynamisch ist und das ist jetzt
tatsächlich etwas wo ich sehr bewusst
auch jetzt mich heute noch nicht
abschließend festlege ich mache es davon
abhängig wie die nächsten zehn tage
laufen die kanzlerin hat gesagt das ist
rausgekommen man von der woche und von
vergangener woche
das ding ist uns entglitten in bezug auf
corona sehen sie das auch so
mehr was da passiert ist es im oktober
haben wir ja entschieden ende oktober
dass es
november und dezember damals dieses
lockdown leid so war ja die diskussion
gibt erste maßnahmen gibt und dann haben
wir ja was gesehen was man übrigens
nicht vergessen darf in der in der
diskussion
die zweite welle gegen runter das war
die welle sozusagen november bis in den
dezember hinein und dann baute sich die
dritte schon auf mein eindruck ist aber
ist jetzt nur noch meinen eindruck aus
aus aus den erfahrungen der letzten 12
monate und den blick nach europa das bei
uns sozusagen hinter zweiten werde die
dritte welle begonnen hat und das in
anderen regionen nehmen sie portugal
gerade sehr heftig getroffen sehr sehr
happy mit meiner kollegin in portugal im
engen austausch das ist wirklich
tragisch auch für portugal für die
portugiesen was dort passiert und wir
unterstützen wo wir können das aber bei
uns eben diese dritte werde sozusagen
sich in der zweiten aufgebaut hat und
das hat diese zusätzliche maßnahmen
notwendig gemacht dann noch das risiko
der mutation wo wir in der nächsten
woche erste ergebnisse er war noch
darüber repräsentativer als die einzel
ausbrüche wie weit sich in deutschland
schon schon verbreitet sind und all das
zeigt uns eben dass wir mit einer
abschließenden bewertung nur wert stehen
noch warten sollten wir lieben sie das
war neben der kanzlerin markus söder als
bayerischer ministerpräsident der macht
jetzt ordentlich dampf gegen sieben wenn
ganz viele interviews sagt das geht so
langsam mehr sagt impfen entscheidet
über leben freiheit und künftigen
wohlstand und sagt eigentlich ist sommer
viel zu spät wie nehmen sie das wahr und
sie haben ja wie weit war dass sie jetzt
gerade eine große oder kleine ist markus
söder macht ist der satz hieß ja
bundeskanzlerin und dann kam das mit sie
das wusste ich nicht mal so sehr ich
meine ich meine die frage so zu sagen
warum markus söder mit dem sie ja
eigentlich meinen dass gutes verhältnis
hatten so schien es zumindest warum da
jetzt so gegen sie schießt können sich
das erklären
ich nehme das du nicht war markus hutter
bringt als ministerpräsident von bayern
die perspektive ein aus bayern und ich
verstehe euch das thema so steige ich
würde auch schneller impfen also ich hab
doch da gar keinen dissenz also sie
manchmal bist du den eindruck alle
glauben eigentlich hätte die impfstoffe
im keller liegen und will sie nicht
rausgeben
also das ist überhaupt kein dissens auch
ich meinen sie hätten schneller
bestellen müssen das ist was die
menschen kritisieren dieses thema hatten
wir ja vorhin schon ich glaube auch im
übrigen schneller bestellen würde die
situation jetzt im januar jedenfalls
nicht nicht maßgeblich verändert haben
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
mit dem ministerpräsidenten hoffentlich
morgen dann auch zu einer einheitlichen
einschätzung der der lage kommen und es
bleibt weiterhin dabei ziel ist im
sommer bis zum ende des sommers jedem
ein impfangebot auch gemacht soll man
mit emv angebot ist nicht gemeint
irgendwie ein brief geschrieben zu haben
das sind 3 weil ich die frage die tage
mal kriegst du weißt was meinst du dich
mit angebot heißt das ich kriege dann
ein angebot für den impfungen im januar
nein das soll dann mit empfang geboten
einig dass es freiwillig ist das wollte
ich eigentlich damit ausdrücken weil wir
ja eine freiwillige impfung dabei
bleiben und dass sein wollen sie nicht
in der gefahr haben die debatten durch
durch zu wenig impfstoff die somatische
sommer ist ganz wichtig für den nächsten
ein spielfilm in sechs monaten stand
heute mit den lieferungen und
zulassungen rechnen wir noch mit einer
zulassung von johnson johnson nowaks für
weg mit den lieferungen und zulassungen
die wir stand heute erwarten dürfen
können gehe ich weiterhin davon aus dass
wir im sommer drittes quartal im laufe
des dritten quartals jeden der in
deutschland jeden erwachsenen muss ich
auch dazu sagen für kinder gibt es noch
keine zugelassenen impfstoffe aber jeden
erwachsenen tatsächlich wenn er sie
haben möchte zumindest eine erste
impfung das hängt dann vom intervall ab
die ist bei astrazeneca übrigens
mindestens neun wochen zumindest seine
erstimpfungen werden haben setzen können
wie man beim spritzen setzen so sagt der
konsum ist eines der angesehensten
magazine kritisiert dass die
impfkampagne der eu zitat die langsamste
in der wohlhabenden welt ist zitat ende
gleichzeitig wird auch die kritik an
ihnen immer härter
es gibt eine werbung von sixx die
sozusagen mit ihren fehlern werbung
macht wir sehen die hier falsch sparen
richtig sparen
wie gehen sie damit um dass sie jetzt
auch so persönlich angegriffen werden in
dieser situation also das ist jetzt für
sich genommen ja nichts neues aus den
letzten zwölf monaten und auch davor
nicht dass das ist bestandteil
politischen handelns ist das natürlich
in der diskussion wie sie jetzt ist wo
ich das ja auch verstehen ich hab das ja
vorhin als diese gegensätze wir sind in
einer schweren phase wie sie alle sind
ein stück pandemie müde ich da auch die
nerven liegen bei vielen vielen plan
chrome auf das homeschooling das ist ja
nicht das klingt ja fünf mal nette als
es ist das ist stress pur für viele die
diese sozialen nöte die wirtschaftlichen
fragen
selbständige beschäftigte die sich
sorgen machen und gleichzeitig ist da
der impfstoff der den weg raus
verspricht aber im moment zwar wie
angekündigt knapp aber eben sehr knapp
ist und da verstehe ich natürlich dass
da emotionen frust wohl fragen sind und
dass am ende ich mich natürlich dann
auch diesen diskussionen stellen muss
und deswegen sieht sich hier bei ihnen
diskutiert mit ihnen deswegen gehe ich
in andere diskussionen hinein ich würde
noch lieber mit bürgerinnen und bürgern
im direkten austausch sein aber das ist
pandemie bedingt im moment nur
eingeschränkt möglich und können sie
dann darüber lachen oder macht sie das
in so eine werbung 86 ist jetzt eher
bekannt für derartige derartige werbung
das ist nämlich so dass jetzt auch egal
wie es mir dabei geht ich meine
es gibt so viele leute die haben es
schwer in dieser pandemie wir haben
gerade ja auch einige mit einigen
gesprochen
die haben es echt grad schwerer und
schwerer als ich und deswegen ist die
frage ob mich jetzt ein plakat ärgert
oder nicht aber tut es oder nicht
ich kannte uns bist gerade gar nicht
herzlichen dank herr sparen das sie sich
den fragen hiervon bild gestellt haben
und dass sie zu allen fragen stellung
genommen haben dass sie engagiert mit
denen die wir zugeschaltet haben
diskutiert haben und wie bei bild
wünschen ihnen viel glück und viel
erfolg und vor allem dass der impfstoff
schneller nach deutschland kommt
herzlichen dank für den besuch sehr
gerne
[Musik]